all right our next guest is an absolute
hero of mine his name is Dave Rubin Dave
has taken a very interesting path in
life where he was like many of us at a
certain point in time just a drone in
service of the machine when it comes to
a lefty and then like Saul on the road
to Damascus the scales fall off and then
here we are a free thinking man whose
YouTube channel is through the roof
whose Rumble channel is even bigger
whose locals page is one that he owns
and of course you can find all of his
stuff at the Reuben report I'm very
pleased and very excited to say the
great Dave Rubin joins us from the other
side of the world welcome to Sky News
and g'day from Australia mate
Paul it's good to be with you I got to
say man I I've heard a lot of intros in
my day and uh that's a top ten right
there that might feel like that kind of
It kind of encompassed everything you
hit on a little bit of everything I
appreciate that man thank you happy to
help now by the way congratulations uh
you're uh you know father for the the
second time there is nothing harder than
two kids and certainly two kids of
basically the same age I think about
five months difference right now how are
you going with the juggle
yeah I got a nine week old and a five
day old downstairs crazy two months to
the day and uh let's just say it's been
a lot of pooping and crying and
screaming and now there's a kid involved
so it's a lot you know what I'm saying
now also you know on your show just the
past couple of days uh you went out of
your way to explain that at one point in
time uh your son's uh your new son's
name is Luke and that would have been
something to do with Star Wars but
because Mark Hamill is a Nutter you've
had to come up with a different reason
for why you called your kid Luke please
explain to Australia why you called your
kid Luke
oh I'm very excited about this question
uh so look Star Wars went off the rails
obviously with these last three movies
that were horrible I could talk all day
actually about how the prequels over
time are going to look better and better
and I think actually explain a lot of
our political Madness of the day but
we'll put that aside for just a moment
but for years I thought I would have a
kid named Luke because of the original
Star Wars then the trilogy the new
Trilogy is terrible Mark Hamill as you
said I mean he became just sort of a
leftist lunatic I'm pretty sure he
called me racist on Twitter once uh and
then I thought okay if I'm naming this
kid Luke I gotta come up with another
Luke there's got to be another Luke now
of course there's Luke from the New
Testament but I needed something a
little more culturally in line with me
and as you may remember in the final
episode it was a two-part episode of The
Golden Girls uh B Arthur Dorothy's
bornak marries blanche's Uncle Lucas
played by Leslie Nielsen one of the
greatest comic actors of all time
and uh that his name was Lucas we're
gonna just say that he's named after
Uncle Lucas from The Golden Girls see
that's very good and I agree with your
logic but uh you know Frank would have
been okay as two after Frank drebin
Frank Dragon would have been fine I'm a
big Frankie Valli fan I like Frank
Sinatra Frank Frank Frank E was actually
on the list number three get ready for
number three all right no no no no I'm
retiring man this is it yeah all right
now let's talk a little bit about your
journey
um and again
like all people of a certain age and
there's two years difference between the
two of us although obviously you look 20
years younger than I do
um
no it's true the the point is that
understandably we're surrounded by
people who end up being of a certain
politics if you start to get anywhere
near the media or you know the front end
of the plane it's fairly obvious that
there's a there's a well-trodden path to
go on but certainly I know for me that
you know 20 years ago uh even as a young
person in University
I could start to see the garbage that I
just was repeating and because I enjoy
being a free thinker and ironically
because I enjoy being uh cynical and I
enjoy being skeptical and I it means
eventually in the same way that once you
start to sort of poke holes at things
like uh you know faith
then you can also sort of start to poke
holes in the new faith that is wokism
what was the moment when you thought you
know what
um yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna swim against
the tide here one of the reasons that I
love Australians actually having toured
with Jordan Peterson and we did sold out
shows all over the country and then I
was gonna bring my first book don't burn
this book to Australia for a tour in
2020 which got canceled because of kobit
is that the spirit of the Australians
and the political incorrectness and the
and the fun of Australians reminded me
of Americans more than any other people
more than I would say people from the UK
more than more than Canada
um there was really I felt a camaraderie
there and an understanding of similar
issues so for guys like us that are you
know right in that middle uh you know
mid 40s it's right in the center of the
Gen X thing when we were in school and
when we were growing up we had solved
most of the problem we really had we
didn't fully realize it I suppose but I
think that Mo no one was it wasn't
allowed it wasn't okay to be a racist it
wasn't okay to be a bigot even on gay
issues it wasn't cool to hate gay people
anymore we had moved all through through
that for the people that grew up in the
80s and into the 90s into the early
2000s then this this very Twisted evil
woke cult you know seemingly came out of
nowhere about seven years ago although I
think actually it was leading for a long
time throughout you know they they say
the Long March through the institutions
so it was happening at the Collegiate
level really for decades and you got to
give the marxists credit they got into
these systems and they destroyed these
systems so we may say okay all your
ideas are bad you're a bunch of buffoons
and you're socialists and blah blah blah
but you know give the devil is due look
what they accomplished so it's it's not
just as easy to dismiss them like that
as far as my wake up there there were a
couple moments the most famous one which
now I think has been seen probably about
50 million times on YouTube is when I
had Larry Elder on Larry Elder as a
black conservative really a Libertarian
but this is about five years ago and I
was still a lefty we got into it about
systemic racism and he just basically
beat me senseless with facts and instead
of doing what what most lefties do which
is call him you know a horrible name or
cancel the show or kick him out or
whatever we aired it we aired it as is
and a few days later I saw a lot of
people in the comments going you know
Dave kind of listened and I did kind of
listen and from there I started talking
to other people say Dennis Prager Glenn
Beck Ben Shapiro the list goes on and on
and I started finding that although I
had some disagreements with some of
these people on the right and I still do
by the way that they were very open to
discussing them they knew what they
thought and why they thought it and I
found them honestly this was the most
shocking part
I found them nicer that really was the
the real shocking part because you know
there's this meme that's somehow on the
left the left muscle of Tolerance which
so the implication is that the people on
the right are bigots and angry and and
it just simply is not true since I have
gone through this metamorphosis
transition whatever you want to call it
and now I hang out with all these scary
right-wingers they are happier they are
more generous of Spirit uh they smile
more they laugh more and most
importantly they're willing to agree to
disagree so you can sit at a table and
I've done it with with 10 great thinkers
and they don't agree on everything of
course and we can argue it out I'm
talking sitting at a table with Peterson
and Douglas Murray and uh you know Ben
Shapiro and all these guys and we can do
it over some I like tequila they usually
like whiskey we can do it and guess what
we can disagree on a million things
including the nature of reality and then
we're still good to go at the end of the
day and that's very different
unfortunately than what has happened on
the left
people will automatically say they want
to be a flyer on the wall now back of
that I want to be at the table with a
cigar I can't wait to uh to see versions
of this conversation pop up all over the
shop I mean also what's
you know what I'm trying to work out is
I think that in many ways wokeness took
hold because of the the ultimate flaw in
the Death Star of what had been built
that sadly was starting to blow up you
know around our Awakenings is that the
very openness of the people that you
just spoke about the willingness to say
hey come be part of the conversation
meant that people took advantage of that
and they took advantage of it at every
possible level and then they ended up
with the ones who were able to you know
essentially uh become the the the
roommate who eventually kicks you out of
the house
that was a very sad realization for me
to come to actually it was hard for me
to accept what you just laid out there
but I have accepted it uh I've written
about it I I think it's I think it's
true that that unfortunately if you were
to look at your idea set as a hierarchy
right you cannot put tolerance as the
most high Grand Point because if you do
that you will become tolerant of
intolerance obviously this is the
Paradox of Tolerance and liberals
unfortunately liberals who fought for
equality and fought to get black people
to vote and for women to vote and fought
for gay rights all just causes of
equality unfortunately when we got to
the place and from an American
perspective let's say the last great one
to fight was perhaps gay marriage that
was the last sort of real Bastion of
inequality in America and once we got
that around 2000 I think it was around
2015 at a federal level
they needed to to leave well enough
alone
but this is where their endless desire
for tolerance
caused the walksters to come in by no
stretch am I a traditional conservative
I mean no way whatsoever however I I do
believe that I am now conservative in my
ideology and that I'm trying to in some
ways I'm trying to conserve liberalism
but I would say in a broader sense I'm
trying to conserve the ideas of Western
Civilization that your country and my
country and many other great nations are
founded upon yeah look if you have a
look at my voting record it would be no
different than the most staunch of
social conservatives but there's
certainly plenty of things that I'll
disagree with with many of those people
but you end up being in fellowship with
a certain group of people that I again I
say are free thinkers or traditionalists
or all of those things because the the
new left is so radical so aggressive and
in a recent conversation he had with the
comedian Bill Maher who again
vehemently disagree on most things but I
like his style like your good self you
talked about how how you know late night
shows like Stephen Colbert's like the
much of the and I hate the term
mainstream media because by inference
that means that somehow we're off in a
fringe which I think is a problem to
sort of pretend that we're off inside
how about corporate press there you go
right and you talk about everything is
in service of the machine right and the
more that you you know the way the way
that I put it is that everything's about
kissing the ring and the more lovingly
you can kiss it and the more meaningful
you can kiss it then the further you go
up up the ladder but how do we resist
this how do we in our personal lives and
then as a movement start to get some
wins here because it's wonderful that we
can all be pissed off about this every
day but I'd like to turn pissed off into
some wins please
so you know that that moment where I
mentioned this thing about how Colbert
is in service of the machine and Mar
really it really hit him he was like yes
that is it was almost as if he was
looking for the words himself on that
one and I was very happy about that
because Mar to his credit is not in
service of the machine you may disagree
with Bill Maher on everything somebody
watching this may say Bill Maher is
wrong on absolutely everything he has
trumped Arrangement syndrome but Bill
Maher often fights with his own audience
Bill Maher's audience now he said to me
in that same interview same chat that he
thinks his audience is 30 conservative
now you can't be in service of the
machine if you're really talking to all
sorts of different people it's why I'm
very proud of my audience because I if I
was to sell out let's say or try to be
in service of my audience I wouldn't
even know which way to go at this point
because my audience I hope is following
my lead and I'm not following their lead
because then you really end up as
nothing that's what Colbert has become
so when you see these guys Colbert I was
say Jon Stewart unfortunately because he
could have been much better than he's
become uh yeah a bunch of these other
guys Jimmy Kimmel they're just giving
the machine What It Wants oh the
machines for vaccines I'm for vaccines
the machines for mandates I'm for
mandates the machine wants to blow up
Russia I'm for blowing up Russia Bill
takes counter points that make it much
stronger but but to specifically answer
your question which was about what does
someone do to not be in service of the
machine look I truly believe that uh you
know if you if you were to look at this
let's say from a Biblical perspective or
a historical perspective I I believe
that that David beat Goliath I believe
that story is such an innately human
story that the little guy can beat the
big guy Against All Odds nothing is too
big to fail actually uh it you know in
an economic sense things things don't
fail because we keep giving them money
but everything Rome fell everything can
fall so I believe that if you if you
fight for something earnestly and
honestly and you and you learn more and
stay strong and
make good friends along the way that you
can be on this adventure with you know
it's like you can do anything and I
think that that's I think my life is an
example of that and I I just
fundamentally believe it as a human
being
it's a good point the first battle is
the battle within once you can win that
one then you can start to uh you know
Unite with fellow with fellow free
thinkers and then eventually there's
more of us that have the courage to uh
to take on such a small ranty few look
I've taken up way too much of your time
already I hope it's the start of a
couple of conversations we can have but
just before we go
um
Joe Biden this is a bloke who of course
can in my view defy gravity because the
only human being I've ever seen fall up
the stairs
um it seems fairly obvious
um what should happen at the midterm
elections and there'll be a handbrake
put on him it seems fairly obvious that
as a result of his policy set he should
be uh swept in 24 but let's talk about
the elephant in the room here we all
love the bull in the china shop that is
Trump but I've got to say I'm probably
thinking that Ron DeSantis might be a
better person of being able to achieve
many of the things Trump wants to set
out but what's your sense about Biden
again with the machine being able to
pretend that anyone other than the
machine is somehow a virus
about his real chances in 2024 versus
what we hope his chances are in 24.
yeah this is another one of those give
the devil his do kind of thing which is
that Biden may be incompetent he may
have surrounded himself with ridiculous
people like Kamala Harris they may have
hired all of these people because of
diversity rather than skill but these
people are still here they're still here
and don't think that they're going to
give the K the keys to the kingdom away
that easily I said the day that Joe
Biden was sworn in as president that I
did not think he was going to make it
the four years it was very obvious the
entire time during the campaign that the
cognitive stuff was becoming a bigger
and bigger problem and now it's just an
abject disaster which when you talk
about the mainstream Media or the
corporate press they're still ignoring
it they're still ignoring it right now
and that's also one of the reasons that
reasons that so many people are are
crazy about politics because we can all
see something we can see something very
obvious and the media won't touch it so
our reality does not match up with the
media is supposed to be a mirror to our
reality and that that disconnect I think
is causing problems by any estimation
the Republicans certainly will get the
house they should get the Senate there's
a bunch of close races you know I don't
have to bore Australians with the
minutia of everyone but there's very
very close one in Arizona very close one
with Dr Oz in Pennsylvania close one in
Ohio I think the Republicans will
probably get the Senate we shall see uh
and then the real question is of course
what happens in 24 you can already see
what the media here is doing which is
that they're really afraid of DeSantis
of course they hate Trump and they're
afraid of trump but now what they're
trying to do with DeSantis is DeSantis
is Trump but he's worse because he's
competent no as you know so the idea is
Right Trump was Hitler but you know sort
of uh like incompetent Hitler buffoonish
Hitler you know Leslie Nielsen Frank
revin Hitler where now we've got Hitler
with an accountant and that's a problem
so look I I've gotten to know the
governor a little bit I live in Florida
obviously it's the freest greatest State
let me let me tell you one other thing
about Florida that people don't know so
you know we had this horrific hurricane
hurricane Ian uh you know a week or 10
days ago uh it was basically a category
five destroyed I mean it's it's
catastrophic damage of Southwest Florida
one of my favorite places on Earth it
has been rebuilt so fast in in 10 days
they have built Bridges already to some
of the barrier islands there they got
electricity back in in 24 hours almost
everywhere everyone is chipping in here
they had 50 000 electric linemen out in
the field working virtually the next day
this guy is running the state the way
anyone on Earth would want their country
to be run so they are going if you think
what they did to Trump was bad wait till
they pull out the stuff with this guy
but he's good he's decent and by the way
Paul he's a he's a young fella like you
he's 44 years old well I'm never going
to call you the old man but you can lead
the way as the Big Brother let's do it
that way David ribbon what a thrill to
talk to you um look again if our parts
cross it would be be amazing but thank
you so much for spending a little time
with us now and can't wait for you to
come and join us on the set in Australia
one day if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell